- Second game we're
playing against Air Force.
Got late in the game, fourth quarter.
Guy dropped back he threw
the ball to a receiver
coming out of my sideline.
Me and the guy, we went head on.
Soon as I hit the guy,
felt as if every breath
of my body left.
People think commitment is saying,
"Yes, I'll do it on the
days when it feel good."
But I have been committed to everything
that I ever started in my life.
I never stopped and I never quitted.
I don't believe in excuses.
Because the thing about
if you make an excuse,
the thing you have to realize about life,
somebody has it ten times worse than you
and you make an excuse
because you're soft, man.
- In a football game in 2006,
he made a tackle that completely changed
the course of his life.
He suffered a life-threatening injury
that paralyzed his right arm.
It turned him into a motivational speaker
that encourages people to
embrace the challenges of life.
He's Inky Johnson and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'm super curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching the clips,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other can be inspired as well.
When you write something down,
it's much more likely
to stick with you, too.
Enjoy.
- You know why people quit?
People don't have pride in what they do.
You know why people stop?
They're selfish and it's just about them.
When you have a bigger purpose
to why you're doing what you're doing
and you want to honor sacrifices
that others have made for you,
it's nothing for you to keep
going when you hit adversity.
If every decision and choice
you make is just about you,
at a certain point you
going to hit something
that's a lot tougher than you
and it's going to make you quit
because you don't have a driving force
for why you do what you do.
But when I got up to the
University of Tennessee,
it was simple.
It was simple for me to
give everything I had.
My freshman year I played special teams.
My sophomore season I
broke the starting lineup,
had a really strong sophomore season.
The summer heading into my junior year,
I still remember the
day where I was sitting
in our film room and I was watching film
on the California Bears.
My defensive backs coach,
Larry Slade came in the room,
he said, "Inky, I got
some good news for you."
I dropped the clicker,
I said, "What is it?"
He said, "Man, you're a projected
top 30 draft pick, son."
He said, "All you have to do
"is play the next 10 football games,
"you're a automatic multi-millionaire."
I went out of the room,
I called my mother and my
grandmother on a three-way.
I said, "After this season,
there'll be no more struggling."
I said, "We will never miss another meal."
I said, "We will never
experience another Christmas
"where we have to stand
on the side of the curve
"and just be grateful."
I hungered up.
First football game, I
went out played great,
got a interception, shut Cal down.
Second game, we're
playing against Air Force.
Got late in the game, fourth quarter.
Guy dropped back he threw
the ball to a receiver
coming out of my sideline.
Me and the guy we went head on.
Soon as I hit the guy,
felt as if every breath
of my body left.
Body went completely
limp, fell to the ground,
I blacked out.
Never happened to me before.
When my eyes opened, I'll never forget,
my teammates ran over they
said, "Ink get up, let's go."
I said, "I can't."
I said, "I can't move."
He said, "What do you
mean you can't move?"
"You got to lock down
corner, man, we need you.
"Let's go."
I said, "I know, man, but
this time I can't move."
I flipped my head up to the sky, I said,
"God, surely nothing has
happened in this moment
"that can alter my life?"
They got me over to the hospital,
they took me back, they ran CAT scans,
they brought me back into my room
and, all in a 15 second time frame,
the doctor came running
in from the opposite side.
He said, "Hey, get in here.
"We got to rush this guy
back to emergency surgery,
"he's about to die."
I said, "What?"
He said, "Son, you have
busted a subclavian artery
"in your chest, you're
bleeding internally,
"we have to rush you back,
"take the main vein out of your left leg,
"plug it into your chest in
order to save your life."
When I opened my eyes from recovery
the same doctor was over me.
He said, "Son, have some good news
"and some bad news for you."
I said, "You got some bad
news for me after telling me
"I was about to die?
"I'm still alive, how bad can it get?
"I'm still here."
He said, "The good news
is we saved your life."
I said, "Thank you, sir."
He said, "The bad news is,
Ink, you have nerve damage
"in your right shoulder."
I said, "Okay, cool."
He said, "But, son, it's
a strong possibility
"that you probably can never
play the game of football
"again in your life."
I said, "No way."
I said, "No disrespect to you, Doc,
"but, I've been working
for this ever since
"I was seven years old."
I said, "No disrespect to you, Doc,
"but, you wasn't in the park with me
"and my mother when I was seven years old
"and she was sitting in that Buick Regal
"after she got done working at Wendy's.
"No disrespect to you, Doc,
"but you didn't come up
in that two bedroom home,
"14 people sleeping on the floor.
"No disrespect to you, Doc,
"but you didn't miss those
meals and stay focused
"and never made an excuse."
I never cheated.
Like, my conscience, still until this day,
won't let me, I can't cheat.
I can't look myself in the mirror and say,
"Ink, you did a good job,"
knowing that I cheated.
I can't cheat.
One of the greatest pieces of advice
that my mother gave me was this,
"Son, whatever you start,
you make sure you finish."
And the problem with the world today,
people get involved with things
and if they don't like a certain person,
if they don't like the process,
if it's not what they
thought it was, they quit.
And what they don't
understand about quitting,
quitting becomes a habit
that doesn't just affect you.
Later on in life when you get a wife
and you get some kids or you get a family,
it's going to come back to haunt you
and it will one day affect them.
That is why I tell you the process
is more important than the product.
It's not even about the outcome for me.
It's about, can you take
pride in what you do
as an individual?
And every night when
you look in the mirror,
knowing that you gave
everything you had to it.
We have to get to the
point where we're willing
to impose our will on certain things,
impose your will on it.
My life totally changed.
And they gave me an opportunity to stop.
Most people when you give
them an opportunity to stop
while they're chasing something,
they take advantage of it
because they feel as if,
"Man, why did this have to happen to me?"
I felt as if, "Why not me?"
This is the perfect
opportunity to use this
to be a blessing to somebody else.
And you know what?
It's not even about me to be truthful.
It's not even about me.
Now it's about we can, and
people that invested in me
and saw something in me when
I couldn't see it in myself.
At a certain point in life,
it can't just be about you.
The moment that we understand that
and everyday we wake up,
we understand that life
is a blessing and life is a gift
and if you were to check out today,
how would you want to be remembered?
It's bigger than you.
When the bucket first started,
it started over five thousand years ago.
The whole purpose of a bucket list,
if a guy was up on the hill
and he wanted some water
and we couldn't get the guy some water
or the guy couldn't get
down to get the water,
we could put the water in the bucket
and we can get that bucket to that guy
and that water pretty
much gave that guy life.
In some instances the bucket
was used to put out fires.
I believe if you give everything you got
and everything you're a part of,
like giving everything you got.
It's kind of like that quote that says,
"The harder you work, the
harder it is to surrender."
Meaning the harder it is to give up,
the harder it is to stop,
the harder it is to give in.
So, if you give everything you've got
to everything you're involved in,
the only way you're
able to live a full life
is if you empty the bucket.
At the end of every day
our tank should be on E
and the next day our
buckets should be filled.
The only way you can go back to the source
is if we empty our bucket.
We can never go back to the source,
and the source is God,
with our bucket full
and get replenished and get a new mind set
and get a new spirit
and get fresh anointing.
When I empty my bucket every day,
I know the next day when I wake up,
my bucket will be back full.
But the way I empty my bucket
is if I can empty my bucket
and give everything I got
and it gives you life.
If I can empty my bucket
and give everything I got
and put some fire in your life.
If I can empty my bucket
and give everything I got
and it inspires you.
If I can empty my bucket
and give everything I got
and it empowers you,
my job is done with the
way that I live my life.
But the thing you have to understand,
in order to live a full life,
you have to empty your bucket.
But the thing I can guarantee you
about emptying your bucket,
your family's life will be made richer,
your workplace will be made richer
and you as a person, when you
look in the mirror at night,
you will have this fulfillment,
you will have this joy,
and you will have this
peace that comes over you
and you will say, "Man, I
gave everything I had today.
"It wasn't about my circumstance.
"It wasn't about my position.
"It wasn't about pleasing my boss.
"It was about me taking pride in what I do
"and the person that I am
and giving everything I got
"to everything I'm involved in."
Can I be honest with you?
They cut me six times down my left side.
One time across the left side of my neck,
one time across the right side of my neck,
twice through my right ribs,
cut out my right peck, bottom of my armpit
to the bottom of my hand,
350 staples in my body
and the bandaged me from
my neck to my knees.
This is not lip service.
I got to be honest with you.
There was days to where
if I could've laid there,
I would've laid there.
But my spirit said,
"It's not who you are."
My mentality said, "It's not who you are."
I don't know about you all,
but I'm a fighter, man.
I fight for my goals.
I fight for my dreams.
I fight for the things that I represent
and the things I'm a part of.
I dare you, the things that you do,
the things that you're a part of
and the things that you're connected to,
I dare you every single day to show up
and give everything you got.
I dare you every single
day when you wake up
you understand you represent something
a lot greater than yourself.
I dare you to go with 15 represented,
give everything you got.
Go home to your family,
go to your careers,
give everything you got to
every aspect of your life
and I dare you to watch what happens.
As a matter of fact, like my
five-year-old son tells me,
"I double dog dare you."
(audience laughs)
I don't believe in excuses.
Because the thing about it,
when you make an excuse,
the thing you have to realize about life,
somebody has it 10 times worse than you.
And you make an excuse
because your soft, man.
(audience applauds)
I never cheated myself.
Ever since I was seven years old
and everything that I did,
I took pride in what I did.
I firmly believe the harder you work,
the harder it is to surrender.
You see, a lot of people understand,
if you go through life
and you cheat yourself
there is going to come a time
when you meet a certain piece of adversity
and if you're not who
you're supposed to be,
adversity will always introduce
you into who you really are.
If you haven't been working hard
and you haven't been sacrificing
and you haven't been emptying that bucket
and you haven't been going all in
in every aspect of your life,
it's going to crush you.
It's going to make you give up.
It's going to make you stop.
It's going to make you make excuses.
But if you work hard, if you
got a certain person in you
that when you at adversity
and you at opposition
and you want to make excuses,
then that person inside you says,
"Man, you ain't built like that.
"You know you better than that.
"You know you're not like that, man."
You deal with it and keep
going and you embrace it, man.
That's what life's about.
That's how people get stronger.
People don't get stronger
by you making excuses.
People get stronger by when
you go through adversity
and you go through
trials and tribulations.
You look at it and when
it hits you in the face,
you back up a little bit,
and it hits you again,
you back up a little bit
and you stand back up and you say,
"If that's all you got, you in trouble."
When you think about life,
everybody wants the prize
but nobody wants the process.
Everybody wants the championship
but nobody wants the day-to-day.
Everybody wants to win games
but nobody wants to put in the work
that it takes to win games.
In the Bible, it talks
about in Proverbs, it says,
"The laborer's appetite works for him
"and his hunger drives him on."
So, my question to you all is,
what's your appetite for winning?
Because if you have an
appetite for winning,
your hunger will drive you every day.
Your hunger will take
you to the weight room.
Your hunger will take you past 32.
Your hunger will take
you past the opposition.
Your hunger will take you past adversity.
Your hunger will take you past
the trials and tribulation.
Your hunger will take you
to that fourth quarter
when there's four zeroes on that clock,
you have emptied that bucket,
you have given everything
you had in that game.
See, it's that sort of mind set, man,
where you attack this thing.
The game of football,
it's not about skill.
That what people miss the boat on.
It has nothing to do with skill.
It has nothing to do with a 40 yard dash.
It has nothing to do with
jumping a 40 inch vertical.
What this game is about, it's about will,
that's it.
It's not about skill,
this game is about will.
So, the moment that you
make up in your mind
the day that you make up in your mind
that you are going to
play this game for God
and give everything you got to it,
you can't help but to
give everything you got.
That's the moment that you will realize
this game has nothing to do with skill.
I've seen plenty of talented guys fold.
I've seen plenty of talented
guys get hit in the mouth
and they didn't want it.
I've seen plenty of talented guys
get punched in the face and
they go back to the sideline
and they stand beside their coach
and they don't want it no more.
They make up excuses.
I've seen plenty of talented guys,
they ran a 4.2 in a 40,
they bench press 325 pounds,
and when third and one came
up they tapped their helmet
to come out of the game.
That has nothing to do with skill.
But I thought I was all in
and I thought I was giving
it everything I had.
My father would say to me,
"Son, I need you to empty your bucket.
"Son, I need you to
give everything you got.
"Son, no matter how hard you work,
"there was somebody beside you
"that works even harder than you."
He would say to me, "Son,
what brings you here?
"You have two more years
"that you haven't even tapped into yet.
"You haven't even pushed
yourself to the limit.
yourself to the point
"to where you feel that
you can't go anymore.
"You have to dig a little bit deeper
"and you have to push
yourself a little bit further
"and you have to go a little bit harder.
"You haven't even reached that point yet,
"If you can push yourself to that point
"to where you have to
dig a little bit deeper,
"to where you feel as if
you're about to pass out,
"you're working so hard,
"that's when you come and talk to me."
If your life doesn't have purpose
and life is like a pencil with no end.
It has no point.
Every day you get up, you
don't have any direction.
But when you get up every
day and you have a purpose,
you have a paralyzed right arm and hand
and they say, "Hey, man, you
can't use that arm anymore."
I say, "I'm using this arm every day
"by the way that I live my life."
Because my life has purpose.
I don't live my life for me.
That's why some of the decisions
and some of the choices
that I had to make, nobody understood.
Because it wasn't about Inky Johnson,
it was about those that
paved the way for me.
I was honoring them.
And about the ones that
were coming behind me,
I had to leave a legacy for them.
Every day you wake up, make
it bigger than just your job.
That's how you become a champion.
That's how you really all live.
That's how you empty your bucket.
You can't just empty your bucket
and call yourself a champion.
If you just come into an office
or you just do your job
and you do it great.
You do a great job, but
you're a public success
but you're a private failure.
You're a public success but
you're a private failure.
You don't give everything
you got to your family.
You don't give everything you got to God.
You see, when I speak, I'm not
talking about just football.
When I speak, I'm just not
talking about your job.
I'm talking about taking
every aspect of your life
to the next level.
That's what emptying the bucket is.
See, when I step on the stage
and I give everything I got,
when I get home tonight, I
don't care what time it is,
I'm going to wake my wife up,
I'm going to wake my kids up
and you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to get on my knees
and I'm going to pray there.
(audience applauds)
Doctor walked by my bed, he said,
"Ink, we'll get to know each other well,
"you'll be in this hospital
for the next 40 days."
I walked out of that
hospital on the third day.
I was back in class the next week.
I was back at practice in the
sand pit with my teammates
the next week.
I had to learn how to
write all over again.
I had to learn how to walk all over again.
People come up to me all the time,
"Ink, how did you do it, man?"
"How did you make it out
of the hospital, man?"
"How did you do it?"
It's cute to them, right?
It's cute, it's cute to them, right?
"How did you do it, man?"
And people don't understand when I say
the process saved my life.
They don't get it.
When I say the process saved my life
and the process is more
important than the product,
what I'm trying to tell 'em was,
when I was in park with my
mother when I was seven years old
and she was sittin' in a Buick Regal,
that saved my life.
When I was up every Saturday
at 4 o'clock in the morning
running two miles to a fire station,
two miles back home, that saved my life.
When I never cheated, that saved my life.
When I didn't let my
teammates give up and quit,
that saved my life.
Because my arm and my hand was paralyzed,
my spirit wasn't, my heart
wasn't, my mentality wasn't.
I was the same man.
I just had a paralyzed right arm and hand.
It couldn't stop me if it wanted to.
I couldn't quit even if I wanted to
because of the spirit and the soul
that resided in Inky Johnson.
The game created that.
The process created that.
So, understand, when
you're playing sports,
it's a blessing because you're
in a controlled setting.
It allows you to build your character.
You have a bad practice,
come back tomorrow,
have a good practice
and make it up, buddy.
Have a bad day, come back the next week,
have a good day and make it up, buddy.
It allows you to build your character.
So, one day when you face
real life opposition,
you can reveal your character
and what you're really made out of.
Process is more important
than the product.
ESPN called me.
They did a story on me this past summer.
But they call me one day.
I picked up the phone they said,
"Is this Inky Johnson?"
I said, "Last time I
checked, I'm Inky Johnson."
(audience laughs)
They said, "Is this this the same guy
"that said if you could
change what happened to you,
"you wouldn't?"
I said, "Absolutely."
They said, "It's our
understanding the game of football
"meant the world to you."
I said, "At one point, it did."
They said, "It's our
understanding that your family
"was banking on you making it to the NFL
"so they can have a better way of life."
I said, "Yup, that's correct."
They said, "We're coming to see you."
I said, "All right, cool, come on."
They said, "But we don't
want to see you in Atlanta.
"We want to see you in Neyland Stadium
"on the exact yard line
where your life changed,
"the same time of day.
"The only thing that won't be
present is Air Force's team."
"All right, cool."
So, they take me to Neyland Stadium,
they put me on the exact yard
line when my life changed.
They said, "Now, tell your younger self
"why you wouldn't stop
that injury if you could.
"If you could be in the NFL right now
"making millions of dollars,
"tell your younger self
why you wouldn't change
"that situation if you could."
I said, "The reason I wouldn't change it,
"believe or not, it has
nothing to do with me."
On a personal level he
thought I was going to say,
"Because of the man that I've become,
"the perspective that I've acquired,
"my faith has been fortified."
He thought I was going to
say something like that.
I said, "No, it has nothing to do with me.
"It has everything to do with the lives
"that have been affected by
the result of the process
"and the thing that I
represent in the world,
"what my spirit represents."
When somebody see me,
they think perseverance.
What my spirit represents
when somebody see me,
they think, "Don't quit."
What my spirit represents
when somebody see me,
they think, "That's a quality
individual right there."
What my character represents in the world.
Every single day we're
putting some thing out,
like that represents something.
When people see that, they think,
it's a thought that comes to the mind.
When he said gold
standard, he gave me that.
I felt a certain type of way.
When he gave me the gold standard
I felt different, gold standard.
I felt like that went with me.
Because I think in what I do,
the line of business I'm in,
I'm the gold standard
because I don't compromise.
Every single day I'm a
give you my very best.
You can bet your bottom dollar
every single day I'm a bring
that gold standard to life.
I'm not just bringing it
in one aspect in life,
I'm bringing it in every
single aspect of life.
I'm not going to be one of
these people in the world
that's a public success, but
they're a private failure.
I mean they give everything
they got to one aspect of life
but the other areas, they lack off.
No, I'm a give every single thing I got
to every aspect of my life
because I represent something.
When people see me they think something.
Whether that's character, never giving up,
never surrendering.
The thing that we can never do
is forget what we represent
because that's how guys
end up under a bridge
on a cardboard box asleep.
They forget what they represent
when life hits them with adversity.
My only charge for you,
never forget what you represent.
I am not here for me today.
I am here for everyone of you all
because I kept going because
I knew the day would come
where one day I'll be standing in front
of a group of children and tell them
regardless of what happens to your life,
regardless of the adversity,
regardless of the opposition,
regardless of the trials and tribulation,
nothing can stop you.
The only thing that can stop you is you.
No situation and no circumstance,
no piece of adversity
can define your life.
Never let a circumstance define you.
You see I knew something about you.
I can speak from a certain place.
I knew something about you
without even knowing you.
I know that if you wanted
to come into this school
and do what you have to do, you can do it.
I know if you wanted
to go into a classroom
and get straight A's, you can do it.
I know if you wanted to go to college,
you can do it.
I know that you can become whatever it is
that you want to become.
But it's like that quote, "You
can lead a horse to water,
"but you can't make it drink."
You see, I can tell you
all the right things.
I can stand up here and say a presentation
but if you walk out of these doors
and you don't apply it to your life,
what good was it?
You see, I'm not so concerned with,
you know, you having
dreams, you having goals.
I'm concerned with the process.
Because a lot of people want the prize
but not many people want the process.
A lot of people have the will to live
but few people have the
will to prepare to it.
The process is more
important than the prize.
The process is coming in to
the building day after day,
giving everything you got
to mold yourself into the
individual that you need
to become in order to
make those things happen.
You know the reason you set goals?
The reason you set goals and
the reason you have dreams
is not for the outcome.
The reason you set goals and
the reason you have dreams
is to become the person
that you need to become
in order to make them manifest into life.
You see, young people, the road to success
is constantly under construction.
With plenty of potholes
and plenty of speed bumps,
with plenty of detours,
with plenty of problem spots
to give up.
But, just as if you were in
the car with your mother,
you find a way to get
over that speed bump.
You find a way to get around that pothole
and find a way to get to that detour.
The only thing about life,
that destination may be that goal
or that dream or whatever it is
that you aspire to do with your life.
One thing that I can tell you right now.
I'm not anything special.
But the one thing I can
guarantee you young people,
and I'm a leave you with this,
if you don't give up,
if you don't stop,
if you don't give in,
nothing will defeat you,
nothing will conquer you,
and nothing will stop you.
Never give up, never stop,
never doubt yourself.
You always believe, there's always hope
and there's always somebody inside you
that's stronger than anything
that life can throw at you.
I had been working my whole life.
What I didn't understand,
by being determined
to chase something, by
being committed to it
and what commitment is.
Commitment is staying
true to what you said
you were going to do long after the mood
that you have said it in has left.
You see, people think
commitment is saying,
"Yes, I'll do it on the
days when it feel good."
But I have been committed to everything
that I ever started in my life.
I never stopped and I never quitted.
So, by being committed to
everything that I started,
I finished it.
It built a certain type of spirit.
It built a certain type of mentality.
It built a certain type of individual.
Now, I couldn't quit even if I wanted to.
I couldn't lay in the
bed, even if I wanted to.
I couldn't stop even if I wanted to.
I had too much sweat equity in my life
and everything that I was doing.
Because I understood my
existence wasn't about me.
I went from me to we a long time ago.
I understood the process is more important
than the product.
It wasn't about the outcome for me.
Whether I made it to NFL or not,
that was inconsequential
in God's plan for my life.
But I was going to fall
in love with the process
because I understood by falling
in love with that process,
it was going to turn me into a machine.
- Thanks you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Marc Clark,
I hope I pronounced
that okay, asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Inky say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What lesson are you going
to take from this video
that you will immediately
apply to your life
and to your business?
Leave it down in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Felipe.
Thank you Felipe so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and making that awesome
video talking about it.
I'm glad it had an impact on you
and I really appreciate your support.
- And this books even
talks about the importance
of living with purpose.
Evan has a channel on YouTube,
called Evan Carmichael.
He always says believe.
He says believe is his one word.
- So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- The other day I was trying to kick it
and there was a guy at Texas A&M,
"Inky, I was trying to kick
it in gear, NFL prospect.
"I was trying to kick it in gear, Inky.
"I was trying to give
everything that I had to it
"and I just couldn't take it there."
What's the button on the
game, the X button some?
When you go and the guy
just speed up with a burst?
He was trying to do the burst
and he couldn't do the burst.
I said, "Listen, I don't even know you."
I said, "But I bet I can challenge you,
"why you can't to the burst.
"I don't even know you.
"But I bet you're the type of person
"that when it's something that you like
"and it's something that's easy,
"'Oh, I'm all in, I love it, let's go.'
"But when it's something
that challenges you,
"something that pushes you
outside of your comfort zone,
"you try to find a way to
get around and cut a corner.
"But I got news for you, if
it doesn't challenge you,
"it won't change you."
If it doesn't challenge
you it won't change you.
So, the point when the light bulb goes off
and you say, "Man, I should
be giving everything I've got
"to everything I'm a part of."
The brain is a two
million year old machine.
It adapts to you and tries
to automatically protect you.
When you get in a
situation or an environment
that's uncomfortable, your
brain tries to protect you.
So, what his brain was
doing when he was trying
to kick it into gear, that
he had never been to before,
his brain was saying to him,
"You know you don't work like that."
Like George Clinton used to say,
"You know you don't go hard like that."
Like your lying to yourself.
The reason I say don't
cheat at whatever you do,
the reason I say that is because
the method behind the madness is this,
if you got a goal, a
dream, or a aspiration,
or something that you
really want to accomplish
and you going to be all in that,
you going to sacrifice, stay
dedicated, stay committed,
you are flat out going to get it.
When it come time for it manifest
and you have given it everything you got
and it comes time for it to manifest
and it doesn't manifest the way
that you want it to manifest,
I can wipe my hands and I can say,
"Okay, I guess it wasn't
in the cards for me.
"What's next?"
But the thing I can't do is say,
"Man, this is the goal, this is the dream,
this is the aspiration,
these are the things
that I want to do with my
life and I start cheating
and I start cutting corners.
Then it comes time for
that dream, that goal,
or that aspiration to manifest
and it doesn't turn out
the way that I want it to turn out.
I say, "Man, why didn't
I get what I worked for?"
Knowing I didn't work for it.
You know the amazing thing?
We got people that live
in the world every day
and they expect results that
they haven't even worked for.
I got news for you, man.
You can lie to a coach,
you can lie to a teammate,
you can lie to a parent,
you can lie to a mentor,
but the one thing that will not give you
what you haven't worked for is the ground.
It knows how much blood you've shed.
It knows how much sweat,
how much sacrifice,
how much dedication,
and how much commitment.
People are rewarded in public
for what they practice in private.
Period.
The whole time in life you got
to live with the thought of,
"What if I gave everything I had to?"
Just what if.
Just think about the mentality
that you will possess
if you gave everything you had
to everything that you were a part of.
Even if it didn't turn out the way
that you wanted it to turn out.